Despite accusations of formulaic storytelling,
moviemaking is not a perfect science.
It’s an inherently human endeavor and as
a result, things go wrong.
In the hustle and bustle of set-life, where
emotions run high, it’s inevitable that
someone will get hurt.
And hey, if you like what you see, subscribe
to our channel, but in the meantime here are
10 Popular Actors Who Hurt Their Co-Stars.
Idris Elba, Star Trek Beyond
Stage combat is not an exact science.
But, as your mother probably used to say,
“it’s all fun and games until someone
loses an eye”.
For Idris Elba and Chris Pine though, the
fun didn’t actually stop.
While shooting a fight scene for Star Trek
Beyond, Elba clocked Pine for real, resulting
in a massive shiner overtop one of Pine’s
trademark baby-blues.
The surprise meeting of fist and face didn’t
dampen anyone’s spirits though.
The actors laughed off the accident pretty
much immediately, and the bruise was so impressive
it actually made its way into the movie.
Which probably saved Pine some time in the
makeup chair.
Dave Bautista, Spectre
To call Dave Bautista an “intimidating individual”
would be a dramatic understatement.
With years of experience in the WWE, his transition
from small screen brawler to big screen badass
is a natural one.
Fans are looking forward to seeing the actor
reprise his role as Drax in the upcoming Guardians
of the Galaxy sequel, but they might also
recognize him as Mr. Hinx from 2015’s Spectre.
Bautista has plenty of experience flinging
giants around, and if Long Distance Human
Throwing was an olympic sport, he’d take
gold every time.
Things on a movie set are pretty tightly controlled,
but in the middle of an intense fight scene
it’s easy to get caught up in the action.
The actor threw Daniel Craig so hard that
he needed knee surgery and two weeks off.
It was a total accident, but 007 was probably
grateful for the time off.
The Millennium Falcon, Star Wars - Episode
VII: The Force Awakens
Before you run to the comments section to
tell us that an object cannot be considered
an actor, we gently remind you that Wilson
the volleyball was the REAL star of Cast Away,
Thomas the Tank Engine has been carrying his
own franchise for years, and Doc Brown & Marty
McFly would be nothing without their sweet,
sweet DeLorean.
One of the biggest celebrities to emerge from
Star Wars lore is Han Solo’s trusty ship,
the Millennium Falcon.
And big ol’ Falcon went a little haywire
during filming of the series’ 2015 installment
The Force Awakens.
One of the doors fell on Harrison Ford while
filming and broke his leg.
Obviously the ship is getting old, but apparently
it’s also getting a little crotchety too.
Lawrence Tierney & Quentin Tarantino, Reservoir
Dogs
Tarantino is a polarizing filmmaker.
His movies are violent, profanity-laden, and
propped up by a series of pop culture monologues.
Since Tarantino has been on the scene for
a couple of decades now, the director has
established his style and amassed a hardcore
fanbase in the process.
But back when he was the new kid on the block,
Tarantino got more sass than he expected and
ended up in a tussle with Hollywood royalty
Lawrence Tierney.
Apparently the actor didn’t trust that Tarantino
knew how to make a movie, and the altercation
escalated into a full-on slugfest.
This all happened on the first week of filming,
so not only did the two men not want to work
together anymore, they also didn’t have
to.
Jennifer Lawrence, The Hunger Games franchise
Chuck Norris isn’t the only one roundhouse-kicking
his way through Hollywood anymore.
A new player has entered the game, and her
name is Jennifer Lawrence.
The actress learned how to do a bunch of cool
things in preparation for her role as Katniss
Everdeen, lead heroine in The Hunger Games.
And while some clever editing and a pile of
money give the impression that her days were
action-packed, filming a movie is a whole
lot of “hurry up and wait”.
Almost nothing happens in one take— and
pyrotechnics don’t clean themselves up—
so Lawrence and actor Josh Hutcherson had
plenty of downtime to practice and goof around.
It was during one of these sessions where
the actress’ roundhouse kicking connected
with her co-star’s temple, making him see
stars.
If we had to get kicked in the face by anyone,
we’d pick Jennifer Lawrence too.
Dolph Lundgren, Rocky IV
Fake fighting is almost as hard as real fighting.
The meticulous choreography can interrupt
the flow of an actors performance.
Not to mention that when it’s done poorly,
it’s so, so obvious.
When Sylvester Stallone and Dolph Lundgren
were filming their infamous showdown from
Rocky IV, both men quickly grew tired of faking
it.
After a couple of takes, the two decided that
if the hits were going to look legit, they
would have to be legit.
Stallone may have been ready to rumble, but
his body wasn’t.
And after taking a REALLY hard punch to the
chest, the actor’s heart swelled so much
that he had to spend over a week in the hospital
because of it.
James Franco, Annapolis
There is no doubt that actor-turned-director-turned-student-turned
Oscar-host James Franco is a thespian through
and through.
By this point, he’s attended like twenty
universities and has become more confident
in himself and his craft.
And rightfully so.
But while filming 2006’s Annapolis, the
actor acknowledges that he still had a lot
to learn.
Franco made himself an enemy in co-star Tyrese
when he insisted on punching him for real
during fight scenes and wouldn’t stop.
Franco chalks it up to being inexperienced
and taking a stubbornly realistic approach
to his character.
Tyrese chalks it up to Franco being an asshole.
Quentin Tarantino, Inglorious Basterds
While it might be edited to make Christoph
Waltz look like the jerkiest-jerk who ever
roamed the earth, Quentin Tarantino is responsible
for this one.
“But wait a minute!” we hear you cry,
“Tarantino isn’t in Inglorious Basterds!”
Well actually, we’re both right!
In the scene where Diane Kruger’s Bridget
Von Hammersmark is being choked to death,
it doesn’t just look like she’s dying,
she actually is dying.
And at the hands of her director.
Tarantino’s face isn't in the movie, but
the hands around her neck are his.
During an interview, he argued that the changes
happening in a human eyeball during death
can’t be faked, so he had to do it for real.
We know Tarantino is old-school, but next
time maybe he could use a little CGI instead?
Jared Leto, Suicide Squad
First of all, let’s get one thing straight:
not all wounds are physical.
So if the person playing the sadistic psychopathic
character in your movie is also a method actor,
things might get… intense.
In preparation for his role as the Joker in
last summer’s Suicide Squad, Jared Leto
took himself to some dark places.
As a result, he was arguably the most talked
about cast member during production.
And probably had the least friends too.
Leto sent some pretty nasty gifts to his cast-mates,
freaking out co-star Margot Robbie so much
that she was scared to even be near him.
If you’ve seen the movie, you can understand
why that would have been a problem.
Margot Robbie, The Legend of Tarzan
Let’s be real— “doin’ it” can be
awkward enough when there’s an absolute
minimum number of people involved.
But throw in a camera, director, and crew?
Talk about nerve wracking.
That’s why actors get paid the big bucks.
Because in addition to heaps of potential
awkwardness, there’s also a chance that
the talent could get hurt.
While filming the love scene between Margot
Robbie and co-star Alexander Skarsgard, that’s
exactly what happened.
The Legend of Tarzan director David Yates
wanted the sequence to have an “animalistic”
feel, which makes total sense given the context.
Robbie accidentally went a little too far
and ended up injuring her bed-mate.
Good luck trying to explain that one to the
workers compensation board.
If you liked this video, head on over to our
channel and check out a few more.
If you’re pickin’ up what we’re puttin’
down, then hit “subscribe” and join the
family.
It’s that simple.
Thanks for watching!